Now that we've taken a look at some of the templates,
we're gonna hop into the first project
that opens by default in Twinmotion.
But first, let's get to know the UI.
So we'll take a look at this first here in the slide.
So you have this to refer to later,
you're reviewing the course,
but we'll hop into it in a little bit
to really see it more in person and live.
But just briefly, we'll go over this.
You'll see the top bar area,
which is where the File menu,
Import and Export will be used,
as well as some preferences
that you can change Twinmotion to be accessed there.
Then you'll see the number two, which is the header.
That's our typical area right along here.
That's where you can click things like the templates,
the learning and plugins, and back to the home screen,
or rather the opening screen.
Now the third is a very important area,
not that the others aren't important,
but the number three area is the library.
This is where we access everything from HDR environments,
materials, vegetation, as well as other asset libraries
that we have at our disposal to import into Twinmotion.
Now the other areas, number four is the transforms area,
which as it says is where your scale and move and rotate
as a pretty typical thing in a DCC program,
but also a color material picker,
which we'll briefly go over.
And then we'll also see the viewport,
which is your area that you work in.
That's pretty typical.
And then the scene panel over here on the six,
this is where it stores things like an outliner.
So things like Maya or Blender or even Unreal itself,
we have an outliner.
So this is what you will see here in your scene panel.
Now there are other panels down here as well
as the XYX panel, position, rotate, and scale,
ambience, which we'll go over briefly,
as well as some properties we can manipulate.
Now number eight is the docs.
That's where you're gonna see various things
via your medias, other things called the configurations.
These are all outside
of what we're gonna be discussing today,
but you can refer to it here
or in documentation at a later time.
So next we're gonna move into navigating around our scene.